the number one show on television this
show has really hit a hit a nerve with a
lot of people Yellowstone is officially
coming to an end the final episodes of
the fifth season will air on the
Paramount Network in November it's ended
Good
I refuse to be sad about you should too
it's unclear if Kevin Costner who's
reportedly been making 1.3 million per
episode will return for what Paramount
calls the Epic final cycle what a great
day for the state of Montana
or two next it's been a dramatic week
for Kevin the Yellowstone News comes
four days after his wife Christine filed
for divorce she was spotted out
yesterday shopping in Santa Barbara
without her wedding ring we're already
at War the 68 year old actors also had
issues and tension with showrunner
Taylor Sheridan I'm not trying to make a
TV show I don't want to I want to make a
movie you see in one hour increments
and Paramount is banking on Taylor his
massive deal includes at least 10 shows
including the new Espionage Thriller
special ops lioness with Nicole Kidman
and Zoe Saldana this first look debuted
today and this is interesting The Wall
Street Journal reports today that the
showrunner rents out his Texas ranch for
production for 50 000 a week and also
herds of cattle at 25 ahead things we
lose to keep you fed now a lot of the
horses in your projects are yours I got
about 20 of them really and Kevin he's
been focusing on his multi-part Western
feature Horizon directing producing and
starring in it that's awesome
congratulations it's a bunch
but there's good news for Yellowstone
fans a sequel is coming no title yet but
many current cast members will join
Matthew McConaughey in the spin-off to
go up some structure or like I've got a
call time I got lines I got things I got
a character that sounds like a vacation
right now so how will Yellowstone end
will Kevin's character be killed off
here's what his TV son Luke Grimes told
us a couple years back Taylor knows How
It Ends and he's told me that he's like
I know exactly how this ends do you want
to know from him he's like you're going
to be there and I was like thank God
okay
[Music]